Ukraine is a pretty big country uh 44 45
million people when the Russians decided
to invade it by on all fronts it was
clear they were taking on a pretty
ambitious uh operation and Western
analysts said that if they're trying to
invade and hold a country that doesn't
want you there
um the forces that they were deploying
didn't really look enough so I think
what we're facing now is the problem
that Mr Putin has if you don't win
quickly you begin to lose politically a
quick military win is what's required if
you don't get it then the political cost
mounts quite a lot and that's where Mr
Putin probably finds himself today so
let's have a look at what's happening in
kieval course Kiev is still not
surrounded and forces that are trying to
get to Kiev are being attacked the lines
of communication are being disrupted the
ukrainians are putting up a really
staunch a series of attacks on those
lines of communication and they're
moving really quite slowly in conchiv
which should have been the most
vulnerable city right near the the
Russian border quite pro-russian in its
background and history they are still
fighting in Cargill it hasn't fallen and
if we now have a look at genev in
chernohev this is a place that the
Russians said on Friday they had taken
turned out they hadn't then they thought
we thought that they were screening it
so that they could move around it and
carry on moving towards Kiev but in fact
if you screen a place and move on you've
always got the danger that it will stop
fighting in that seems to have happened
again today so again they're lines of
communication look as if they're being
interrupt interrupted and evanchive just
have a look at ivankiv Northwest of Kiev
I think if it's about 40 miles from Kiev
we have a video of an armored Convoy
moving really very slowly it's not
dashing towards Kiev to complete the
circle around the city so there are some
problems there let's have a look at the
down in the South here the Russians are
doing much better they have taken
buryansk and that's confirmed by the
Ukrainian government that is the the
first proper military objective that
they have achieved so they've got
birdians but let's have a look at this
look at Maria Paul and Kirsten they're
still fighting in an area that they
expected to take easily and marry a poll
Mario Paul was the most vulnerable of
all places in Ukraine it was right next
to the separatist entity
um an important port it was already
strangled as a port the fact is here we
are on day five maripole should have
fallen within hours we don't know what's
happening in Mario Paul but whatever it
is it must be quite something when this
is all over one suspects they'll be
making Hollywood films about mariopol
the fact is Mark uh that President Putin
is facing the the problem that he now
has
this operation should have been over in
three days in fact this is day five for
every day that the Ukrainian government
is still on its feet that's a political
victory for them
yeah and uh I mean I I assume that we're
gonna the nuclear
talk about Putin and his Defense Forces
on alert nuclear alert is posturing but
uh you know if what you say is true then
Putin will be getting pretty frustrated
one imagines how dangerous could a
frustrated and angry President Putin get
it ratchets up the tension another notch
Mark I mean maybe more than one notch
but the fact is that these sort of
threats have been made before in 2008
and 2014 when Russia moved into Georgia
in 2014 in the Crimea crisis and
President Putin always meant it as a
sort of symbol to tell the rest of the
world keep out this is not your problem
this is this is something we're going to
deal with they always did keep out in
this case the line is getting a bit
blurred between keeping out and getting
involved so I think there's an element
of desperation in what he says but also
it is dangerous because we don't really
know what sort of mental state he is in
but at the moment it's just a it's just
a piece of rhetoric but believe me the
Western Nations and intelligence
agencies will be watching very very
closely for any movement of nuclear
warheads in in or around Russia
yeah it's all uh just so fascinating
Michael thank you very much indeed